so this october surprise published in
the new york post last week about joe
biden's son hunter biden
is i'm calling it on the verge of
although some people say it already has
spectacularly backfired on the trump
campaign
the entire story published last week was
supposed
to make joe biden look really really bad
it was supposed to prove that joe biden
is corrupt and a bad person
and that so is his son hunter biden
corrupt terrible bad person
and a drug addict not only has the story
failed
to hurt joe biden so far some of what is
coming out as being
joe biden's alleged text messages to his
son
are actually just making him look like a
good kind loving dad an empathetic
person
and republicans have no idea what to do
now before we even get into the
specifics um i
i want to let you know that
we've since found out that the writer of
this story
the primary writer of the new york post
story bruce golding
didn't even want his byline on the
article
because he knew it lacked credibility
many new york post staffers we've since
found out thanks to a great piece in the
new york times
new york post staffers were saying we
shouldn't even be
publishing this story we don't even
trust the reliability of the sources we
question the timing
and we now know rudy giuliani was a big
factor in pushing for the story's
publication so
number one even internally many at the
new york post
knew the story wouldn't shouldn't be
published but it was published okay
first of all the underlying premise of
all of this is that joe biden did things
as vice president because hunter biden
was on the board
of a ukrainian energy company including
getting a prosecutor
fired that main story about
joe biden getting a prosecutor fired as
as a gift to hunter biden
has long been debunked even if you
accept
everything else in the new york post
story is true
it does nothing to change that the biden
prosecutor firing story is a lie
joe biden was involved in the ukrainian
situation with the prosecutor at barack
obama's direction
a coalition of countries was involved in
that the idea that biden went and did it
for hunter biden because of his
consulting contract
widely debunked already okay then some
texts are published as part of this
story
texts purported to be between joe biden
and hunter biden
what we learned from those texts are or
is that joe biden is a caring dad
and talks to his son in a way that i've
never even heard of donald trump
speaking to his children he seems to
love and
and support his son hunter biden it's
clear joe biden
loves his kids generally speaking it's
not super clear that trump does at least
not in the way
that resembles healthy parenting that
helps joe biden it makes joe biden look
better and in the text you also see
again if the texts are real
joe biden say give me a call because i
am sure that my
text messages are a target and indeed
joe biden was right about that
now thirdly nbc news is reporting that
federal investigators are
looking at whether the emails allegedly
describing activities by joe biden and
hunter biden
supposedly found on a laptop supposedly
at a delaware repair shop
those emails are potentially linked to a
foreign intelligence operation
i it's like it's happening again barisma
apparently was hacked by the same
russian intelligence unit that was
involved
in the hacking of the democratic
national committee
in 2016. it's happening again that is
now
being investigated the washington post
also reported overnight
that u.s intelligence agencies warned
the white house last year
that trump's lawyer rudy giuliani was
the target of an influence operation
by russian intelligence rudy giuliani
has since admitted
that it's possible i believe he said
it's a 50 50 shot it's possible
that he was working with a russian spy
on this story don't need to make any
conspiracy just look at what rudy
himself
himself said so far it does not seem
that this october surprise
has hurt joe biden at all it may end up
damaging republicans
it may end up damaging donald trump's
campaign more than anything else
for a second consider how absurd this
all
is the trump campaign is trying to smear
joe biden by releasing
the loving emails and texts that he sent
to his son
guys rumor has it joe biden cried when
his first
wife and kid died what a loser that's
the level of stuff
that they are resorting to and trying to
pull off here and
really i know that when trump does his
rallies and talks about hunter the crowd
boos and cheers and jeers and whatever
it doesn't seem to be uh people don't
seem to be falling for it and what
underlies this
all to some degree think about it
is that republicans consider empathy and
kindness and sensitivity to be
weaknesses
trump certainly sees it that way for
sure this is why it doesn't make sense
to argue with them they can't behave
like normal humans
it could be a result of anger fear
authoritarianism depending on which
group
you were talking about but you can't
reason with them and as i read through
the alleged
texts between joe biden and hunter biden
i like biden more
the only really groundbreaking thing
here that came from this
supposed october surprise is that rudy
giuliani
is now being investigated for
potentially working with russian spies
maybe doesn't come as a huge shock to us
but so far i know that there are some
saying there's much more coming
and it's going to be much worse well
we've got 15 days to go
okay so they'd better get it out soon
what is out so far
does not strike me as even remotely
damaging to joe biden within a few days
we will have
post new york post story polling and
we'll be able to see for ourselves
we'll have more on this on our instagram
at david pakman show
and if you want to see me voting this
weekend powerfully voting
follow me on instagram david.pakman